[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries for
ted lasso yeehaw we're gonna watch this
on this trailer
together uh we're gonna give you some
behind-the-scenes insight into how we
really felt about this
piece of lovely show and uh we're gonna
do
uh some deleted scenes questions and
comments from viewers like yourselves
and then we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer that's
that's how it works um hi i'm wishing
you both such a sunny optimistic ted
lasso filled morning you too how you
doing you ready to get this day red get
this video done
oh good dangly do i'm so excited for
this video
where are my baked goods i i assumed
that on ted lasso day you'd be sending
us all bespoke
treats to who we are as a person
and the connection that we've forged
even though it's only been a few weeks
i assumed mine would be seattle related
just all the time yeah
something says you've been paying
attention to literally everything i've
said
and hanging on my everywhere because i
care about you
i do freebasing with the boss where i
duck under my desk and freebase a little
bit of
rock cocaine before i start doing it
freebase
yeah um but what uh what a lovely
uh little trifle of a show this was um
everybody said it was good and to watch
it i don't think it was as
life-changing as uh everyone said it was
but it was life-affirming and it was uh
it was the right kind of like
24-minute uh uh little treat that you
can watch
uh to perk your spirits up but how do
you guys feel about it
yeah it's a soos phone is that how you
say that i don't know where it's
um but it's definitely it's too soon
it's like you have to do this though
it's a little bit of sweetness um like
hey we said in the trailer it was right
place right time
um i definitely needed something and i
think a lot of people did that was just
like
nice people doing nice things and i'm
also like i'm a ned flanders apologist
so um so in that stupid sexy flanders
super sexy flanders like everyone who
knows me knows like i'm very much like i
like nice things and i like nice people
i don't know how i got this job
because i just enjoyed niceness uh so
this was like
right up my alley and yeah it it veers
into cornball
territory but i'm like a huge cornball
y'all
so i really got into it yeah i
listen i think it's it's it's well done
it's
it's good i'm not gonna argue that it's
not
well executed on everything it's trying
to do terrific
very charming performances there's some
funny
moments it's really well like shot like
it looks cool and
like believably like a premier league
sort of
team or whatever um so so on all that
stuff i i can't like knock it it's not a
terrible show but i
i i don't know it didn't really speak to
me i think the way that it speaks to a
lot of other people it did seem like
it's just it's kind of easy like i'm not
saying you can't make a show that is
like
upbeat and nice about how we should all
be more upbeat and nicer
it's just like i don't know if i really
buy ted lasso in this journey it feels
like this is the sort of thing that
only exists on television and if you
were like ted lasso and you treated
people this way
your results would vary wildly and i
feel like the show
knows that and it's almost trying to
inoculate itself against that
like well you gotta just gotta be nicer
like you're
you're one of the negative like just by
saying this
i'm one of the negative voices that ted
lasso needs to like take down
and it's like i don't like that like i
don't like it's like preparing
for your negativity and ready to like
counter with like nope
there are shows yeah like there are
shows that do this
a little bit with more nuance like a
parks and rec is also a bunch of people
who just really like each other and want
to do a good job
but there's it's still a little bit more
cutting than this good place i think is
probably the best at this
kind of comedy where it's like it
doesn't punch down
um but it's also like very much people
trying to be
nice people and failing whereas this is
like mostly oh i was a grumpy grump
and then this dude with a mustache came
along and that mustache carried me on to
freedom
and literally sometimes all he has to do
to like win the person over
is like a two-minute little like
anecdote
or like giving them snacks from their
home country
it's like come on if you want to do this
if you're going to make a whole show
about how
it's on all of us to be like super kind
to everybody like win me over with it
you know really convinced me
well look uh it's less in the tradition
of like a nice sitcom than it is in like
a like a musical or something this is
he's like
mary poppins like he's just this magic
outside or maybe like a movie like being
there or something where he's just this
the magical guy from out of town that
that changes everybody's life
like it's not in the yeah i like it
better if i don't look at it as a comedy
because it's not that funny um but it is
a very sweet
uh uh uplifting show about a guy who
comes into town and changes everybody's
life
granted he does that incredibly fast and
against people's
own you know motivations they just kind
of turn on a dime because he's just so
gush darn sweet
yeah i think that's what i wanted more
of is like
i wanted it to be more of a journey like
like the nominal villain of the show is
is hannah waddington who brings him in
to this job under false pretenses
because she's got this plan of revenge
but they don't even allow her to be a
villain for
half of one episode she's softened
immediately
we're immediately meant to feel like
sorry for her
and like sympathize with her plight and
it's like come on i like get a little
bit attention like that's what i think
mike sure and stuff like parks and rec
or rutherford falls or whatever does
a little bit better than this is like
it's a little bit of a harder edge and
they have to be
worn down and won over over time like
they didn't feel like a family
immediately in parks and rec it's like
by season three and this by episode
three they're it's like all hugging and
crying they're like done you've been
trying
there's no pretense it's dropped
immediately that these are
hard harsh people i still insisted
yeah you old grinchy old so and so you
have to love this
show or else you're a terrible person
right no it's like i'm the jamie tark
like i get it like
that's what they're doing it's a
strategy if anybody's negative it's like
they just need a good lassoing nobody
makes me cookies this week
and it's like life's not like that guys
come on grow up if someone brought me a
seattle you could be like life
life sucks um anyways let's let's watch
the honest trailer for ted lasso
and we'll we have plenty more to say
about it i'm sure
and you haven't bothered to start your
mythic quest i hear it's good though
but since your iphone crapped out on you
and every new one comes with a free year
of apple tv plus
you might as well check out ted lasso
prepare for a show that feels like it
was based on a dad joke about the two
types of football but was actually based
on a series of nbc sports commercials
how many countries are in this country
four but unlike the geico caveman show
that
yes really happened by the way
um the commercials are probably better
than this show
it is just like an eight-minute short
and it's just packed with all the best
jokes
from the series and if you just want
that and you don't
have apple stuff or you want to just
like you know
get through it real quick just watch
these two uh uh
i'd say commercials but they're like
eight minutes long and well they're
fantastic
well no i would argue that the uh laszlo
holmes
uh nbc ones with chance the rapper the
ones on snl i would argue that those are
actually better
um okay i do think that they're because
they're quicker they're snl so you get
through it really fast
chance the rapper is also like kind of a
fish out of water
i i love ted lasso i love the show i do
think the laszlo homes ones are better
especially
um the the hockey one is noi
i also just say as far as sports
advertising we'd love to see inspired tv
shows
terry tate office linebacker where is it
i i would love to see the tv show that
would uh it would that would be birth
from that
uh you know i mean i think we got we got
lots of uh we got lots of options here
for like our
you know our like starting out in the
world of sports themed advertising move
is space
jam you know we got a whole franchise
yeah yeah and
i don't know if you guys ever watched
the shack and the general
like some sort of sitcom iconic
characters
save some time with the i'm sure there
is at least a script laying around for a
flow from progressive
uh oh sure oh yeah a secret agent thing
or something like that but
give yourself a treat and watch uh all i
believe
10 episodes at the geico caveman
[Laughter]
it's beautiful um all right anyways keep
going we happened
you have a dab of dude seriously don't
don't do that oh there he is
this should have been called possible
odds to actually be
really good it's at least as unlikely as
leicester city winning the premier
league in 16.
i just got asked to be the head coach at
lachester
whoa i mean for the people who aren't
fans of the footy yeah i didn't get this
i had to like look this up
yeah leicester city it's it'd be like i
don't know the most hopeless
franchise in pick your sport baseball
basketball football
it'd be like the cleveland browns times
10 like winning the super bowl
uh it'd just be the most unlikely
possible thing and then the year before
the 15 to 16 season
they have this ted lasso sketch where
he's like i will now manage lachester
city
um so just a weird speaking it into
existence type
it just listen it's the power of
positivity guys
why don't i get on board positivity the
show wants to know why i don't get on
board
yeah that's american superpowers to uh
uh believe even the worst things are
super great and cool and we're doing
great
and we're fine everything's like yeah
what posh british
model doesn't want to hang out with like
a sad
30-something dude from kansas not one i
know
definitely not makes perfect sense keep
going
for 10 episodes crammed full of hugging
learning growing crying
and more hugging and because streaming
services are cheaper than therapy
we're working through all of our trauma
by watching tv comedies
even the cartoons so gear up for a
season-long motivational speech
delivered by the world's first manic
pixie dream dad who's here to change
lies
and shoot you in the face with a fully
loaded pun gun for 30 minutes straight
and our goal is to go out like willie
nelson on a high you know what you do
with tough cookies don't you
dip in milk and they met at his friday
chess club
apparently they liked each other's moves
oh that wasn't a joke was it all yeah
pause i mean that's what i say when the
show is not very funny
is um it's mostly puns and granted we do
plenty of our own punting in the uh in
the starring section of an honest
trailer
that we fart out for about you know 20
minutes tops
i expect a little more thought going
into uh
into a into a series like this because
the comedy the company comes from the
situation
where it's like this super positive guy
dropped into this super cynical
uh cutthroat world but then like you
were saying uh uh
earlier guys it's like it becomes a
super snuggly
everybody loves each other world very
quickly so all that's left is is just
word play
all that's left to do is to just make
funny sounds with your mouth
um so you know but they don't
they don't make them like they used to
that's why we that's why we all watch
office reruns is because like there used
to be
comedies on tv and now they're like this
is about imposter syndrome
like you have to take this seriously or
whatever
yeah yeah i blame the emmys because
everybody was like well we can't get a
drama like there's no drama to emmy so
now we're gonna call
everything a comedy and it's like
everything's not a comedy some of it's a
super hardcore bummer with two jokes
yeah i mean i i do think this actually
does a decent job of just scratching
that like it's a workplace sitcom like
it's
very much by definition a workplace
sitcom like you meet the
the boss and the people around the
office and the co-workers and it's like
it it you know there are season long are
they going to win the
the big game kind of things but it's
it's very episodic
in nature you know and and i think it
scratches that itch and a lot of shows
are
you know in peak tv where like
everything's experimenting and playing
with the format and like one division
and
is it a sitcom or is it some other thing
and and i think it's nice to have a show
that's just very plainly like no no no
it's like about a bunch of people who
work together and like each other
yeah yeah sometimes they date maybe
sometimes they date maybe sold
[Laughter]
make i'll take three seasons was it all
i guess it kind of was meet ted he's
what happens when a golden retriever
humps a motivational poster until ned
flanders pops out
knock-a-doodle-doo and he's up against
the only force
powerful enough to counter that much
optimism
british people
thrill as every type of cynical brit
falls to his toxic positivity
that's a long time to wait ted and
relentless food-based assaults i'll
start bringing these to you every
morning
called biscuits with the boss hey man
you guys gonna be chinchin well we know
you haven't been home in a while so we
thought we'd get some home uh
danielle i know you'll appreciate this
it's the uh uh it's the positive version
of the wu-tang sketch where they
sew the butthole
and feeding you i keep saying if someone
did that with me with like seattle dogs
and
almond roca i would be super happy don't
ask me what a seattle dog is you'll
immediately hate me
what is a seattle dog ah a seattle dog
is a street dog
that has it has to be bought from
someone on the street at two in the
morning
it's got caramelized onions and cream
cheese on it and a little bit of deli
mustard
there it is that's the that's the face
i'm used to
cream cheese doesn't just immediately
like melt and just because
not only melt but it gets it gets
because that gooey paste
yeah yeah it comes it comes in packets
so they just squirt the packet on there
so it becomes like a perfect tube of
cream cheese
um but you just discuss inside your hot
sauce and the dog
is like a good sure you know like a
cheese dog is a good combo so i guess
this is just uh like an l.a
your dog is generally it's not like
great but i mean nothing wrong with like
a hot dog wrapped in bacon the hell you
say
late night bacon dogs are delicious yeah
wrong seattle dog
and feeding me and feeding me seattle
dogs we might be best friends at the end
i don't know
okay keep going i'm good you know
what would you what would you like to be
fed if your butthole was soaked
out of bounds they say into touch ted
we're gonna be like i'm gonna put you on
a really comfy cushion
and keep feeding you you still have a
lot of gaffer i mean
going out to the pitch grass here to
watch practice
training fries called chips chips are
called
crisps and bangers aren't great songs we
still have cookies
or as you all call them here biscuits
right i feel so bad because
it's like any time an english person uh
or a person from the uk
uh interacts with an american this is
like the first 19 topics of conversation
it's like the words are slightly
different
and like we have we actually work with
people who are based in the uk and like
i can see their eyes glaze over
when we're like you call the trunk the
boot well they're
never for whatever reason they're
they don't ever think it's funny the
other way like they're never like
what you call them like they don't care
what we call things they're not
interested
in what our version of a lift is our
media
is everywhere we've dominated the world
so it's everyone's like yeah it's an
elevator we know we get it
it's like everyone in new york delighted
it's like how everyone in new york has
like
complex nuanced thoughts about all the
things that are wrong with la and people
in l.a are like oh yeah it's fun i like
it's great go see a play
yeah i think we're just really excited
because it's the closest we get to
learning a second language
yes because we're never going to do the
work
bob's your uncle i'm going to take the
apples and pears
[Laughter]
i did it you did do it you did the thing
the lamby pick
keep going cookies snooker that's it and
am i getting notes of axe body spray
i think they call it something else here
what does that mean we still
ain't nobody here gonna kiss their
sister well which is an american phrase
that
isn't i'm now realizing does not exist
here i've never heard that it's 20 20.
let's just call them cigarettes
what's a wanker okay we get it different
countries have different slang
that right there's another example of
how our english and y'all's english
sometimes do not jive it's not that
funny
oh dang it i'm going to make coach sad
can't stand
that it's like a puppy dog locked out of
the sausage factory sorry coach
are you ready for some football no good
cause neither is this show because the
soccer gets about as much air time as
the day job's on friends
here we go and there you go
i mean come on players aren't even
sweaty at half time
i mean i found that it wasn't worth
harping on but i found that pretty
egregious is
after practice in the middle of a game
after game whatever like
maybe a light forehead missed but like
if you watch soccer there
sprinting for like i don't know three
hours straight and just completely
drenched
in sweat and they're like oh coach come
on that was a poll showing
um you're not watching this for the
sports
everything else well it's not just the
sport it's like everything else is
just background it's really just this
one
thing that it wants to be about which is
ted lasso's the best
and no one appreciates life like ted
lasso
and everybody should be way more like
this guy and why aren't you more like
this guy and what a great guy
and it does feel like everything kind of
takes a backseat to the point that it's
almost like weird like
they're they're setting up this thing in
the beginning of the season where it's
like ted
doesn't know anything about soccer and
really isn't trying to learn and there's
even an interesting see where a guy
a journalist from the independent he
says his name like 800 times it's a bit
and i'm forgetting it now
but the guy from the independent who's
interviewing him
is like you're doing a crummy thing like
you've come into this community that
really cares about this
and you don't really know anything about
it and you're kind of just fumbling your
way through and you think it's cute but
it means something to them
and i was like that's a great point i
can't wait for the show to deal with it
does not ever deal with that i don't
outsource that it's not
it's not part of the show at all it's
just this guy is a snot and ted needs to
win him over
yeah and of course he does by eating
hot indian food eating hot food is what
it takes to win that guy
it's telling that i didn't really know
what a premier league manager
does um at the beginning of the show and
i still don't i still have no idea i
i assume lifelong friendships birthday
parties
his management strategy is exactly the
same as michael scott's like except
the office accepts that that's a joke
and ted lasso was like what a great guy
yeah he wants to be your boss that wants
to be your best friend it should be a
nightmare yeah
it is a nightmare and i we're happy to
not have one
i mean you do constantly kind of expect
ted to walk into the locker room like
conference room everybody five minutes
it's like he's
he's right there
and nick mohammed is his uh you know
that's that's his uh
dwight his dwight yeah all right keep
going ted lasso may start out as a dope
who can't tell a striker from a scouser
by the end he'll still be proudly
ignorant about the sport he's paid to
coach
find me how that's all sides well no i'm
serious how's that outside i don't
understand it yet
an oath who co-spy on charm while
everyone else does the work
ted really is american oh no offense
coach
making fun of this guy so bad like came
mr rogers pickup drug
yeah surroundings i mean that was a
genuine concern was like
should we do this show at all because
making fun of it
is so sad to be like ripping in a sesame
street
but but i know i don't know abby's
pretty annoying and elmo really gets on
my nerves sometimes
um but a lot there's a lot we could
actually dig in yeah it's like they
found out snuffleupagus was real but
then nobody ever apologized for
gaslighting big bird for like 25 years
and also girls talking like he was crazy
grover you wound up just getting
replaced by elmo that's not cool
would you find like the younger hotter
model and then get rid of the older dude
wait did they kick grover off of sesame
but grover used to be like the monster
yeah he was not he almost
came around and then elmo wound up being
like the guy
and bert and ernie have really faded
into the background too
um i feel like they didn't want kids
asking questions or something
like they slept in the same bed when i
was a kid i'm not
making that up no they did uh they did
the the number of the day song
uh actually kind of slaps now uh they
really they really
even though the count is probably an
anti-transylvanian
trope or something but man the number of
the day song pretty good check it out
i couldn't make sesame street today too
everything's too rope you guys that's
too well for sesame street wouldn't work
it was too raw
um so yes uh with the
the thought was oh can we even make fun
of the show and i think that we
we tread that line but but you be the
judge um
it's it's tough to tough to crap on
stuff that's uh that's just so
unceasingly positive again i feel like
they kind of played dirty pool intent
last so they like they've pre-inoculated
themselves against criticism because the
show in a lot of ways is about
if you're critical of ted lasso it just
means you need
more kindness and love and acceptance in
your life like it's
diagnosing negativity is like the
problem
so of course any negative reaction is
like
what would ted lasso say you know this
is like oh
screw you show i'm allowed i value and
cherish my negativity
you can't have it bye
all right on that note keep going
founding ted is a major league full of
side characters
perhaps because the show has the same
exact plot as the film major league
like rebecca the team owner you'll be
ashamed you didn't recognize sooner
[Applause]
that still blows my mind begins the sub
to her dom
keeley a character who's eerily similar
to jason siddique's new girlfriend
that's also in the show each beard every
king of the hill character is combined
into one guy
the only two players who get any
character development a parade of barely
recognized footballers who we can only
assume had their lives changed by 10 off
camera
and 8. your favorite little introvert
since 10 in scrubs
man bill lawrence is so good at making
lovably weak characters we can all laugh
at
[Music]
his set of go-to moves and i
really don't like scrubs um but i
chalked that up to
not liking zac braff uh and liking jason
sudankus
because i feel like these shows are very
similar in tone and writing quality and
everything
um i guess i just like sudaikis
i think this one i was not a huge scrubs
guy either but i don't know i think it's
like
i think this one is just it's like it's
one notch up like it's it's everybody
who is doing it is like a little more
experienced it's just a little more like
polished and it's like a little bit
sharper it's just less it feels less
hokey like like the the subject matter
is a little corny but
scrubs is like so much of that like mug
kind of like
you know like voices and mugging comedy
and i feel like
thankfully this is less of that stuff
yeah yeah scrubs is definitely like
it's good to put on in the background
while you're cleaning house it's a good
cleaning house show
for sure so of course i loved it i love
friendships yeah
all right keep going cuddle up for the
right show at the right time
because we all just crave some
positivity in an otherwise terrible year
and nothing heals our fractured psyche
like a southern fried alpha male
football coach
who's also a worldly musical loving
feminist who always knows the exact
right thing to say
yeah that's a thing i'd hate to see you
and michelle obama arm wrestle but i
wouldn't be able to take my eyes off it
either even though if you need a person
who acted like that in real life you
would probably
surprise yourself and you'd be 100 right
oh i'm sorry coach i take it back i
believe in you
i just need someone to believe in me
i genuinely think there is like a
pathology about you know the american
uh uh people that we would totally
elect a football coach president if they
oh my gosh
oh yeah oh that's just waiting to happen
isn't there one that was like that's
like now a senator in in florida
right tommy yeah yeah
mr manning
[Music]
definitely peyton manning we would elect
him uh immediately
oh from brady we would we would just
like make it permanent it's it's a
little bit like the rock that like the
rock
will say like voting is good and like
millions of americans will be like i
like the cut of this guy's gym make him
president like
we want any guy who seems like big and
strong and tough who's going to be like
a like america's dad like we we crave
that we have founding fathers yeah it's
right there in the name we want to we
want a daddy
yeah what is our problem yeah what is
our thing with daddies in america
oh it's really unhealthy and gross and
weird for sure what did our dads do to
us
i have answers we could dive into that
on a whole other episode
but instead we'll keep playing the puns
of our starring section
the snuggly american the beautiful shame
shame coach beard that's it that's his
actual name
the water boy tosh spice
assistant to the regional owner harry
styles
david belland lean street hooligans
making a good point mvp yeah it is
ah see there you go
just like han solo love a good point
yeah
jackpot oh
yes yes that's my favorite
that's my favorite joke in the show and
you're totally not watching porn
hey how are you excuse me pause
something interesting about this they
managed to use a ton
of apple products of course which i'm
not used to um
they do appear in other films but they
had this rule
that only the heroes are allowed to use
iphones like you can never put an iphone
in a bad guy's
hand or something like that like that
was those were their conditions
so i i guess like you know that she's
gonna turn good by the end because she's
he's using uh
he's got an ipad oh what a great way to
track that yeah
you can tell anyone with an iphone is
gonna is gonna be
uh a friend by the end so something to
watch out for in future apple
uh things it's like my little pointy
everyone's friends at the end
and here i mean now that we uh uh i
guess we have like a work account but
like
i'm gonna watch mythic quest i'm gonna
watch the quest is
really good the space one is good i also
really like servant on apple
that's the shyamalan one i'll check that
out um
okay yeah well keep going and for the
america
anthology
[Music]
cornballers
don't worry england ted says success
isn't about the wins and losses
it's about helping these young fellas be
the best versions of themselves on and
off the field
twist the knife oh we're the worst a
heartbreaking
victory for you can make fun of us when
los angeles loses the super bowl i don't
know what we yeah we don't care about i
don't know
sorry guys when they cancel a marvel
movie um
we get excited when the lakers win we
don't really care
it doesn't seem like we really care what
people do la is a pretty apathetic
city it's um yeah we just have too many
choices here
too many different types of bacon
wrapped hot dog it's not fair um
anyways uh this was fun uh thank you
guys for watching please like and
subscribe and hit the bell because we do
this
every tuesday we have sju uh sandwiching
that on
on monday and wednesday uh plus other
fun things throughout the week
um tomorrow will be the loki wrap up
oh final final it's the final loki
check that out uh now this is
demonetized yeah
it's as five as we can do
[Laughter]
we just got sued by europe europe the
continent and the band
weirdly okay uh roll the deleted seats
and more hugging and if you're asking
isn't this supposed to be a comedy
comedies aren't supposed to make you
laugh anymore as they're supposed to
make you feel
and ted lasso is like a 30-minute
therapy session
and our goal is to go out like willie
nelson on a high
yeah that's right ted won't wait until
fourth and long to pun
oh dang now i'm doing it too starring
better off ted foghorn legwork
the lasso of truth yankee doodle dandy
paused away x-life from shame to fame
the beard's gambit ted's beard oh yeah
because
that's timid brandt captain britain
not so keen that thing you douche
friday night live viewing beard and
ted's
excellent adventure i like that one
adorable bosses
winker man the legend of tell us that's
good
thank you to the hollywood foreign press
uh i mean this is the for me the coolest
thing that a group of
you know like uh that's
that's nuts especially oh that's crazy
okay all right um
any excuse to play this i read this book
to my my son otis
called the three questions uh by leo
tolstoy when's the right thing to do
uh what is the right thing to do and
then who's the most important one
better uh then you know
you know then then and don's right i
gotta wrap this puppy up
you know never been never been my forte
a little windy little windy as my aunt
loretta would say
okay give jason today cause all the
awards but never in the same time zone
that he's in
yeah i just feel like i mean that's how
i feel on sju which is sad because it's
like 11 a.m
and i should be well and cogent but um
yeah that was just a great uh all-time
great acceptance speech where did you
get a hyper color sweatshirt i haven't
seen one of those since
junior high they're back
a lot of you're probably too young to
they're still big in europe i imagine um
really no i don't know
i can't imagine that yeah uh all right
uh so that was fun let's move on to
uh what we got from the chat what you
guys been saying
um evan j pretzel back with a question
what commercial could seriously make for
a good tv show or film franchise
anything that you see um like it's been
so long since i've seen a commercial i
know
right because i'm always skipping
through stuff i think i don't watch like
football games which are the only places
people see commercials now
right i think like the epic journey of
the can you hear me now guy and how he
got
from one thing to the other because now
he's on sprint
right yeah maybe that could maybe that
could make a good it would be a little
door
but i'd like it it'd be like a comeback
success story from
i'd watch like the adam mckay behind the
scenes of like how they got him to
switch
you know like yeah real like the big
short but for how they got the
verizon guy to like i want i want the
contract
i want i i want some sort of true crime
documentary or docu-series about the
the death and rebirth of mr peanut i
think that's what we really do
like the whole behind the scenes saga of
the decision to kill
mr peanut the recognition of like my god
what have we done
the baby nut years like you know just
like give me the whole story
front to back that's what i want yeah
that'd be that'd be good
bring back chris if you guys if anyone's
listening and has the power to do that
but
um i just like that the nutrigrain bar i
feel great we could do it like crank
have you ever seen that ad i feel great
yeah
it's just like a 90 minute uh he has to
go from bar to bar to
to just keep the keep the streak alive
what was that movie
with the twin peaks guy where like an
alien makes you do crime
it'd be like that uh i'll think of what
it is
later wait hang on there's a movie with
a guy from twin peaks where an
alien kyle mclaughlin john mclaughlin
yeah and it's like well
spoiler alert it's an alien but it's
like it basically makes people go on
crime sprees and then hops from body to
body
wow i don't know it's so good oh i think
it's denzel in it no
no that's fallen he's got that he's got
a flame thrower at the end
it's so cool oh send me that yeah
uh it's from the hidden
check out the i did not see yeah they
hit 1987. i'm saying yeah i've never
seen
one of a good one the all-time great
action gems i think you did spoil it
because the setup is just a cop and an
fbi agent race for answers after
law-abiding people suddenly become
violent criminals yeah i think it's in
the execution
it's all in there aliens yeah i'm not
saying it's aliens
but it's aliens sorry about that but uh
but you wouldn't know otherwise so
um all right uh fiona gilbert no
relation ass uh was the honest trailer
timed because
england made it to the final stages of
euro 2020 or is it pure coincidence and
this is because season two is really
soon
it's the latter sadly we don't if we
were precogs we would not be doing any
of what we're doing right now um but
great timing for us you know
yeah it worked out but no it's not yeah
um arthur mingo asks can we get lon to
say bah humbug
i don't believe it
nice uh mark sheridan asked does this
series make you want to visit the uk
i mean i no um
i already did like i've been to the uk
and it's yeah charming
i've been to london twice it it reminds
me of los angeles in a lot of ways it's
just like a complete sprawl with like
uh little pockets of niceness
and character but otherwise it's just a
big mega city you know
seen one you've seen them all uh but uh
i imagine there's more to the uk than
london and someday i will return
and i've been to a couple a couple
random spots i also went to attack
called taunton in a little area called
mine head on the on the coast
mind head mine head m-i-n like there was
a mine there
and that's where things came to a head
yeah uh
great um ombre to california does long
like paddington
i do i really like the paddington films
it's not i'm not anti-anything being
upbeat you just gotta you just gotta
earn it and and if the message is
hey you the person watching this you
need to be more upbeat
you've got your work cut out for you i'm
not saying it's impossible
it's a steep hill to climb yeah uh final
question
langley neely writes uh speaking of
confusing category nominees thoughts on
the emmy nominations i was genuinely
shocked by some of the noms in a good
way
now i did a cursory browse this morning
because i was like oh do we get
nominated for an emmy and it looks like
they deleted our category or am i just
not
wait aren't we the other enemies i
always thought we were the side emmys
yeah
creative artists rainbows yeah this is
the end the endings this is the main one
not the creator randy rainbow still got
nominated for something so i feel like
we
open the category i mean maybe they just
moved stuff over
and i don't know but i do know we're
usually the creative arts emmys which is
not this
emmys this is the prime time okay well
it's important further
further inspection is needed so uh yes
my only thought was uh i i looked for
myself and didn't find it so that's my
only thoughts
so far uh did you see there's lead
actress in a
limited series this year is the most
ridiculously stacked it's
it's elizabeth also for one division
it's kate winslet
for for mayor it's anya taylor joy
for queen's gambit it's michaela cole
for i may destroy you
and then cynthia for that aretha
franklin she's like the
she's like the you know the bottom spot
it's just it was great actually i really
like that i just don't think as many
people have seen it but those other four
like
the four most popular performances of
the year yeah
all head-to-head who knows what's gonna
happen there
only one can actually be the best
performance
uh we'll see that's the buy-up only by a
lady dude to get their own
yeah they did just sorry they're doing
lady acting which is doing
it's it's different they're acting like
girls
um also a a headline that's kind of
fortuitous for us is ted lasso just set
a record for the most
nominations for a freshman comedy did
you see seven
ted lasso actors are nominated in
various
acting that's stupid like almost the
entire
are there even almost the entire main
ensemble is
like ted's nominated uh nate's nominated
rebecca's nominee like like the whole
main cast
wow that's all right um british people
don't we love watching them
say dude just can't get enough put it in
my veins
and tea what's the deal with tea that
i'm sorry
that's not a thing americans drink tea
are familiar with tea
it's true not like you go to england
like brown water
i've never met an american who is not
intimately familiar with
tea but you know what's weird is when
you go to europe they all of their
coffee is like
espresso based it's always like you get
an americana which is like espresso then
they
dilute it with water no one like brews a
pot of coffee which i feel like you're
missing out over there
90 of the coffee i had while i was in
england was
disgusting like i gave up i gave up
after about like two days because
they're like this is all terrible they
don't know what they're doing they don't
they don't understand coffee you just
have to switch over while you're there
yeah um anyways that's enough insulting
our uh our uh ancestors today you make
sandwiches that's basically just like a
bun with a little butter on it and then
bacon in it and that's the whole
sandwich and it's like this is a
beautiful
thing oh they do that with fries too
yeah a bacon buddy is what they call it
and it's
incredible okay yeah we're missing out
yeah um
all right y'all uh thanks for hanging
out today uh please come back
please come back uh because we'll be
doing it again next week
um for
uh silence i really don't know yeah
yeah you do uh it's it's a
uh it's black widow it's black widow
so solve that one uh uh take a guess in
the comments what you think it might be
about
um and we'll see you next week thanks so
much for watching bye-bye
you caught us red-handed
[Music]
you